and the author and psychologist Dr
Jordan Peterson Jordan great to have you
back on uncentered and may I wish you a
very happy New
Year same to you pierce and thanks for
the
invitation let me ask you do you believe
in New Year's resolutions do you have
any are they
pointless no I I don't think a vision is
ever pointless I think it's a good idea
and the idea of a New Year's resolution
is very ancient idea you know you can
you can trace it all the way back to
ancient Miss Mesopotamia so it's the
death of the old that's the old year
often symbolized by an old man and then
the birth of something new and you see a
conjunction between that and the
Christmas celebration as well and so
when you have the opportunity to start
again you can start fresh you can lay a
New Vision on the world and that's how
we cope with the world is by laying a
vision on it consciously or
unconsciously better to do it
consciously so there's any number of
reasons for New Year's
resolutions do you have
any well I make plans all the time so I
don't specifically have New Year's
resolutions per se um I've built that
process of making plans and generating
Visions into my life for a very very
long time uh we developed software to
help people do that there's a site
called selfauthoring.com that helps
people elaborate out a future vision for
example and so it's something I do on a
very regular
basis the other thing that's happened to
you in the last since we last spoke to
each other is you become a grandfather
again your daughter Michaela gave birth
to little boy George and there's a
lovely picture that our viewers are now
seeing of all of you together let me ask
you Jordan you've spoken a lot about
being a father about parenting what's
the difference between being a father
and a
grandfather well I think what what's the
colloquial way of dealing with that I as
a grandparent you have all the pleasures
and none of the pitfalls essentially you
can stand back farther you can be just
more pure fun as well because the
primary responsibility for disciplinary
interventions at least in principle has
been devolved to your children and then
it's very interesting to watch them do
that too and it's reasonable for you to
take a back seat because well it's now
your children's responsibility to deal
with their children children and you can
stand in the background and be good fun
and wise counsel and that's a very good
deal let me ask you about the future of
the of the world if you look at the last
50 years the rate of progress the change
has been so extraordinary that we have
to assume that that will continue and of
course there are a lot of apocalyptic
warnings about things like climate
change and so on the risk of potential
nuclear war and so on when you look at
your little grandson who's a little baby
what kind of world do you think he may
be living in in say 20 30 years
time well I would hesitate to Hazard any
guesses about a time that distant things
are changing so rapidly that I can see
about a year into the future and that's
about all that's true personally and
more on the world stage I would say in
general the world is the same as it ever
been you know it has an AR iple or
Eternal nature but it's unfolding at an
unprecedented rate and so we're seeing
the nature of its reality more starkly
and more clearly and with greater
consequences for ill and for good than
has ever been the case in the history of
the world and so the one thing that's
going to be certain for my grandson is
that things are going to be happening at
an unprecedented rate you know and
that's a revolutionary change in and of
itself um I think that the future isn't
written in stone so to speak speak and
that we all have the option to tilt the
world uphill or downhill with every word
we utter and everything we do and what
that means for us now and for my
grandchild is that the world that's
going to unfold could be a far better
place than it's ever been perhaps even
inconceivably better or it could be a
hell that would make World War II or ma
China or stalinist Russia look like a
warm-up and you see Pierce as we become
more technologically powerful the
consequences of our moral or immoral
action start to mount and so we have
become staggeringly more technologically
proficient ese especially in the last
100 years and we need to develop a wise
morality that's commensurate with that
te technological power and that's really
being true I would say since the end of
World War II with the development of the
of hydrogen bomb technology that was in
the early 50s the atom bomb was enough
but the hydrogen bomb really put the cap
on it so I'm hoping that we will develop
an increment in conscious wisdom that
enables us to deal with the unbelievable
opportunities that are provided to us by
our our remarkable and and
rapidly rapidly improving
technology what is fascinating I think
it was a survey that just just came out
actually about teenage mental health
issues and what it what it established
was that the actual quality of life for
teenagers is probably as good as it's
ever been I mean on almost every metric
now this is the best time to ever be
alive uh and they the survey concluded
it's not events themselves that are
causing so much anxiety amongst young
people and it's a real epidemic I think
amongst young people it's not the events
themselves it's it's it's through what
device and how that those events are
being disseminated and that really
resonated with me because I really do
believe that kind of constant dopamine
effect of selective often very
misleading or just downright false
propaganda video imagery and so on uh
bombarding young people's minds it
cannot be a good thing what do we do as
technology gets ever more advanced what
do we do about
that well one of the things we need to
realize at a very deep level is that man
does not live by bread alone and that
means that the provision of ample
material security is insufficient people
need a vision for their life they need
something to strive for that's worth
striving for and they need structures
that protect them from too much
uncertainty and Chaos that's why in
October for example we hosted the First
Alliance for responsible citizenship
conference and
dedicated it towards trying to elaborate
out a better story a story is a
framework that provides a vision and
that provides security and we've
provided our children with unparalleled
material security and opportunity as you
pointed out in ever increasing amounts
and with increased ease but at the same
time we've sunk into a very deep
spiritual malaise a malaise that's so
deep that people are willing especially
on the atheistic materialist side to
dispense with the idea that life itself
has any Transcendent meaning whatsoever
and the problem with that is that you
can starve to death spiritually in the
midst of Plenty and that's certainly
what's happening to young people now
part of that is also a technological
consequence of the of the gadgetry
itself you know I've seen especially in
the last years so visiting young people
in my family and among my extended
friends who who will attend a social
event even a private social event with a
small number of people and be entirely
glued to their phone the entire time and
I don't think that it's so much even
what they're consuming on the phone
that's the problem although that's also
a problem especially if it's a Non-Stop
diet of apocalyptic nihilism it's also
what they're not doing while they're on
the phone which is also the same with
children it's interfering with their
ability to establish actual embodied
relationships right like if you're on
your phone all the time for example you
can't develop the social skills that
makes you a desirable and challenging
and provoking conversational partner for
example in a social setting and you
can't replace that with the empty
virtualization that's offered by text or
the immediate Amusement of the iPhone
that's that's that's an inappropriate
subst subtitute it's no different than
the substitute of pornography for
sex and so there's no way you can be
healthy and have that occur because the
other thing Pierce is that we
conceptualize sanity very stupidly as
modern people because we're
atomistically individual we think of
Sanity as something that you carry
around in your head or that's a
characteristic of your psyche and that's
actually not
true it's said that a mother is never
any happier than her least happy child
and it's very difficult to be sane in an
insane relationship and what that points
to is the fact that we find opportunity
and positive delight and Security in a
network of embedded social
relationships and the sanity is actually
the harmony that prevails at all those
levels of nested relationship you can't
be sane without friends you can't be
sane without a mate even though a mate
can also drive you insane saying we're
not we're social creatures to the degree
that you can punish the most antisocial
and Psychopathic individuals imaginable
by putting them in solitary confinement
and the iPhone technology the the the
cell phone
technology has interfered with the
establishment of fundamental social
relationships and so it's going to
severely disrupt mental health and then
the content which you pointed to is also
an issue young people are being fed a a
constant diet of insistence that all
human ambition is nothing but the
manifestation of a planetary of a
planetary devouring Force right and
that's the patriarchy let's say and this
idiotic and absurd insistence that human
activity per se is going to produce an
environmental Calamity of unprecedented
proportions and immediately you know
unless we all cut down on our living
it's no bloody Wonder they're depressed
I mean how can can you not be depressed
when you're fed that diet
nonstop
yeah the the interesting thing is what's
happening I think to the the woke world
if you like which has been a sort of new
form of fascism albe ironically driven
by people who would say fascism is their
number one enemy um I watched the Golden
Globes last night for example uh an
event that was taken off air last year
in a about uh racial bias and so on in
the institution that puts it on uh and
it came back on really fascinating to me
I watched the whole thing for three
hours no political speeches no virtue
signaling no grandstanding people
basically did what Ricky jves told them
to do three years ago which is get up
you know thank your agent and and sit
down and just celebrate making movies or
TV shows um is this a sign Jordan do you
think thing I I felt that there is a
movement going on now of a real backlash
from perhaps a majority that's been
silent till now has just said enough and
that even Hollywood has woken up to the
reality that people who watch the movies
and TV show they don't want to hear this
stuff all the
time well we put politics first and
foremost and partly the reason we did
that was because any higher AIMS in some
ways collapsed I suppose that's part
part and parcel of the famous death of
God if what's highest spiritually and
transcendentally disappears then
something else steps up to take its
place and in our society that's either
been a nihilistic bent that's very
powerful or politicking in general and
the problem with that is that you're
supposed to Render unto Caesar what is
Caesar and unto God what is God gods and
the mistake that entertainers make is
that they regard what they do as mere
entertain
mment Hollywood stars and all the people
who were involved in producing the
narratives that entice and and and uh
compel us they're serving a master who's
High far higher than anything merely
political and when they bend their art
to serve a political Master they distort
the higher to the lower to their own
detriment and people aren't so so that's
the philosophical problem with an artist
being becoming political it's art
supersedes Politics the art should never
be subordinated to serve the political
because then it gets not only does it
get propagandistic it gets dull and
contemptible no one cares what a star
thinks about Trump especially when what
they what they have to say about Trump
can be said just as coherently by your
demented
neighbor but the fundamental problem is
that we don't understand that the story
is the thing and these Artists movie
stars who are so privileged and often so
talented and and and have this wonderful
opportunity to shape the culture from
which politics is Downstream have
forgotten how sacred you might say their
mission truly is and some of that's even
a false humility you know I suppose many
Hollywood stars believe that their
luxurious and privileged life isn't paid
for by the grueling necessity of having
to make a movie which is more something
like a great adventure and so they feel
guilty and feel that they have to serve
something real but the problem with that
is is that well who said the political
was real first of all and second there
is absolutely nothing wrong with being a
profound Storyteller in fact apart from
being a profound artist and perhaps
profound spiritually I can't think of
anything that is more clearly dedicated
to the highest possible cause and when
we forget that we destroy art and we
destroy the people who make it and we
undermine our culture and it's possible
as you pointed out given this pullback
let's say at the globin at the Golden
Globes that the storytellers are
starting to realize that subordinating
their venture to the idiot political
especially a victim victimizer narrative
which is the lowest form of the
political is counterproductive in every
possible way including financially hence
Disney yeah I mean and also I was struck
by the juter position of the Globes with
the Rich and Famous turning up and
celebrating their art which is great and
I totally agree with you that the art
actually is a is a great calling it also
great escapism when times are difficult
you know in the middle of a pandemic and
cost living crisis and Wars raging again
in Europe and so on to to be able to
escape into the world of television or
movies is actually really important for
people it's good for people's mental
health um but back in Britain we've had
this Dreadful Scandal involving people
who are not rich and famous they're just
ordinary hardworking members of the
public who were running little post
office branches delivering the mail to
people and because of a faulty Japanese
uh computer system suddenly hundreds and
hundreds of them were accused of fraud
because the computers were malfunctional
and they were in many cases put in
prison they were all given criminal
convictions many suffered appalling
mental health many lost everything they
had four of them committed suicide uh an
absolutely appalling Scandal and yet
here we are 20 years later with it still
unresolved no accountability the woman
who ran the post off at the time got
honored for her work not punished the
senior politician whose job it was to
oversee this was so dismissive that he's
now being lambasted by the victims but
remains a leader of a major party in
Britain and you've got this Japanese
company Fujitsu who have seen no uh
reason so far to offer any financial
compensation to these poor people what
do you make of that
Scandal well the first thing I would say
is that the rush that we're all engaged
in to automate
everything means that we can automate
our willful blindness our stupidity and
generally willful blindness and
stupidity are in more plentiful Supply
than wisdom and we are in terrible
danger of automating tyranny and and and
what yeah well willful blindness is the
best way to put it know all these
systems that we're developing are
essentially equivalent to the
unconscious mind they're they're the
implicit structures that shape our world
and you see this making itself manifest
every everywhere so your country the UK
is completely covered with closed
circuit TV cameras right we're
automating we're we're risking
automating a kind of tyranny that's
absolutely unimaginable and the problem
with that is that especially once you
get AI involved you actually don't know
what's being automated you don't know
what biases and errors are being built
into the system and you're foregoing the
possibility that those Accused by such
systems will be able to hold someone
human capable of suffering for their
sins let's say responsible for the for
the Injustice this is an
unbelievably uh major source of current
threat you know I've been using chat GPT
and Elon musk's Gro as research
assistants continually over the last few
months and they're unbelievably
intelligent systems and remarkably
helpful as research assistants it's like
having a team of competent Masters
students in multiple disciplines more or
less at your back and call but they also
lie constantly they and they're biased
probably because they've been trained on
a surfite of recent Publications
politically biased in a way that's
absolutely unconscionable and we
genuinely risk automating our proclivity
towards slavish slavishness and tyranny
and that's going to become a much worse
problem um it's going to threaten us
digitally because our digital identities
are already controlled by quasi or half
automated machines and it's going to
threaten us directly as it did in the
case of these postal workers so you know
you know increasingly you can't move
from country to Country without going
through a facial recognition system know
you're monitored by systems that will
increasingly be beyond our understanding
and beyond our control and we have to
step so carefully to put those systems
into place properly that it's hardly
imagin
and we don't have the legal framework
even in place now to ensure that that's
going to be possible your digital self
and mine as well have virtually no
protection and you as you extend
yourself out into the virtual world
there that is you just as your
reputation can be destroyed virtually
you're extended now into this virtual
space and who has ownership over the you
that exists in this virtual space is one
of the main reasons for the recent
strikes in Hollywood is that so many
actors are really concerned about AI
just generating their image and using it
without their control or permission and
I can see that happening not just to
actors but to members of the public
everyone as you articulate I mean AI it
seems to me is a a bit like the internet
when it first came along it's an
amazingly powerful tool which can do so
much good I can imagine in the world of
medicine for example it's going to be
curing all sorts of diseases that were
beyond the ability of of a human brain
to cure uh but simultaneously I'm always
mindful of what Professor Steven Hawking
said to me in his last television
interview which was that when I asked
him what's the biggest threat to mankind
he said when artificial intelligence
learns to self-design and you can see
from Elon Musk and others How concerned
they are they are that we may be
reaching the point where AI can start to
think for itself and at that point it
may just render humans redundant to
their higher purpose
well that points back to a point that we
discussed earlier which is the necessity
of very careful movement forward on the
moral front while we're designing such
systems you know my sense is that and I
know the legal system is you know years
behind in this regard and that really
means by normal standards centuries or
at least decades behind the generation
of someone's virtual image falsely
should be a crime equivalent to
kidnapping and I don't know how long
it'll take us to sort out the legal
framework that makes that possible
because essentially part of what's
extraordinarily valuable to you about
you is your reputation right that's your
social currency it's also the
fundamental axum upon which your sanity
depends if you were Rak over the coal
sufficiently and your reputation
destroyed the probability that you would
descend into a suicidal depression is
extremely high or that you would be
traumatized by it because you're
reputation marks your value among others
your currency and now we have a
technology that enables someone to steal
a reputation and that would be your
digital image let's say and to have you
say or do anything they wish and that
can have and will soon have cataclysmic
effects on people and it is a crime that
should be punishable by well I do
believe it's a crime that's equivalent
in seriousness to kidnapping and it's
going to take us a while to sort that
out legally like a a good
while yeah I completely agree it's also
going to be used of course in the
political world for very nefarious
purposes a lot of propaganda being
pumped up we've seen it I've seen it in
the Israel Gaza War we're seeing it
already in the buildup to the American
election later this year on the on the
US election I've been here now for 10
days or so in America you can feel the
heat building to the Iowa caucuses next
week and then New Hampshire and so on uh
this is the real kind of kickart for the
US election um I can also feel the
temperature on both sides of this debate
ratcheting up uh it seems to me that
there's no short-term solution to the
toxic tribalism that infest not just the
American political system but the UK
political system in fact political
systems everywhere what do you feel
about that what what is your what's your
sort of prediction for how you think
this election May unra
here well I think the danger of
artificial intelligence generated false
news skewing the election results is
extremely high because you can imagine
and I can't even see how this won't
happen you can imagine the unbelievable
utility of a well-timed fake video
account of trump or Biden doing
something clearly reprehensible timed
mere hours before an election and I see
at the moment absolutely no way that we
can protect ourselves against such
things I think for me at a deeper level
the solution to the problem that you're
describing is a psychological solution
that is
inevitable in light of our increased
technological
power people are going to have to
understand more consciously that
the errors that they propagate morally
the acts of willful blindness pretending
that they're doing something other than
they are doing morally grandstanding
outright lying or avoiding the truth
with all this technological power at our
hands the cataclysmic consequences of
those moral errors are radically
magnified and I I don't see that there's
an alternative to that as we get better
at doing good things faster we
simultaneously get better at doing bad
things faster and at a wider scale and
you know I concluded decades ago and
this is partly why I stayed as a
psychologist rather than say pursuing a
political career is that we've always
known in the west that the weight of the
world rests on our individual shoulders
right the central story of the West is
that each person is to take up their
cross and carry it uphill and that
that's a Divine calling and that the
fate of the world in some sense depends
on that and we're going to see Pierce in
the next 30 Years we're going to see and
it might be a lot faster than that just
exactly how true that is as the evidence
for the world disrupting consequences of
our hypothetically trivial errors start
to become increasingly manifest
increasingly and rapidly manifest at lay
lay out the underlying archetypal
structure of reality you know the
endless battle between good and evil and
the most profound commentators on such
battle have always concluded that the
fundamental
line is drawn in the human soul and if
you want to get the Demons of the world
under control you better start with the
demons in your own skull and if you
don't think that's enough to keep you
busy that just means you haven't looked
inside with enough what courage and
perspicacity there's plenty of disorder
in your own soul to occupy yourself with
for the rest of your life and this is
something uh we're either going to learn
this
voluntarily consciously and Wis ly or
we're going to be Beat to Death by our
own stupidity and that's going to happen
quickly in many many ways you can see it
unfolding well you can see it unfolding
around us
now so two questions on the US election
can Donald Trump win and would it be a
good thing for America and the world if
he does
win well I think he can win assuming
that he'll be put on the ballot as far
as I've been able to tell and God only
knows how reliable the polls are and
generally not very because the questions
are usually biased
unconscionably he he's certainly popular
enough to win I don't see another
candidate emerging on the Republican
side at the moment who poses a threat
there are some interesting people
running that's for sure it looks to me
like DeSantis is a pretty competent
character and Vic ramaswami is at
minimum very interesting and bright and
quite the disruptive Force um on the
Democrat side you know Dean Phillips who
almost no one knows about and who the
Democrats are doing what would you say
everything they can to to keep it that
way he's an interesting alternative to
Biden I don't think Kennedy has a chance
although there are some things about him
I like I think Trump could win will that
be good it depends on what he does if he
wins it depends on the manner in which
the victory takes place it depends on
whether or not the people on the more
conservative side of the spectrum are
able to extend a welcoming hand to those
who are more on the Progressive side and
it certainly depends on whether those on
the Progressive side are willing to
dispense with some of the ideological
stupidity that possesses them that is
generating an endless sequence of unne
necessary culture War know the the left
in particular has become 100%
preoccupied with the most pathological
possible political narrative which is
essentially a victim victimizer story
that you can understand every element of
social interaction among humans from
Marriage upwards to the political in
terms of who's got the power who's the
oppressed and there's nothing in that
but an endless recipe for
not only for the most bitter of Soul
devouring resentments but for the
application of any form of Vengeance
imaginable it's I it's I can't imagine
this something that possesses the
universities as well there is nothing
more toxic than a victim victimizing
narrative and that certainly possesses
the radical left in particular to the
nth degree and there's nothing in that
but disaster so you know it's part and
parcel of what we've been discussing
there's going to to be very rapid change
not least on the Electoral front in the
upcoming year and how that goes will
depend on how people conduct themselves
and and ever more so so we can pray that
we're terrified enough of the potential
negative consequences and enticed Enough
by the potential positive consequences
to walk ever more
carefully we'll see you if you're if you
have big toys you better be a big boy
and we don't have big toys we have giant
toys and they will stomp us into the
ground unless we're wise enough to guide
them
properly you know the fascinating thing
about Trump for example is I always say
to people I've known him a long time and
know him very well he's got the thinnest
skin of any person in public life he
reacts to absolutely everything and goes
to death gone one with in a heartbeat U
but he also has the thickest skin he can
soak up stuff that would crush any other
political figure in history in seconds
this is a guy facing nearly a hundred
criminal charges and yet all that's done
is actually make him more popular I mean
it it's we are into completely Uncharted
Territory with Trump as a as a political
figure aren't
we well I don't think the Democrats
could have done a better job of keeping
the name of trump alive if they would
have planned to do that and it's
certainly possible that in some ways
they did plan to do that because the
scuttlebutt among the political
theorists that pass for wise men among
the Democrats is that well if Trump is
the candidate then Biden can beat him
it's like well not necessarily I
wouldn't bet the farm on that although
that's probably already occurred
and you know Trump
is canny enough to know that in some
real way
all publicity is good publicity and it's
certainly the case that the Democrat
persecution of trump and I think that's
the right term has kept him alive and
has also cast him so perversely in the
role of victim that the Democrats
themselves are always what would you say
trumpeting as being allied with it's
it's an unbelievably demented move on
the Strategic side you know my sense was
if Biden would have taken a careful look
at the Abraham Accords which he
certainly should have because then we
wouldn't be in the situation we're in
right now in relationship to Israel
let's say he could have given Trump a
medal clapped him on the back said good
job mate and maybe he would have ridden
off into the sunset now that would have
meant the Democrats would have had to
contend with someone like DeSantis let's
say who's at minimum hyper competent and
I don't think that was in the cards so
instead they determined to play idiot
play itical games not like those aren't
well known on the Republican side and
they rais Trump from the dead and they
do that
continually
so well so I I think personally and this
is just a guess because what do I know I
think that the most likely outcome is
that Trump is the next president that's
what it looks like to me so I think
that's you know unfortunate I think I
think that that that could AB so
divisive that's the problem yeah yeah I
mean I I you know it was interesting
because when I did the Celebrity
Apprentice the first series of that back
in 2008 I saw Trump across a boardroom
table for three hours a night for about
six weeks and you get to know somebody
pretty well actually because a lot of it
didn't get aired if he showed even an
ounce of the empathy that he showed to
people then if he showed more of the of
the humor without being vicious if he
showed less of the punching everyone in
the face and more of occasionally
putting a metaphorical arm around people
I think the perception of Trump would
change dramatically but he he seems to
think the only way to be a political
leader is to be a kind of swaggering
trash-talking very aggressive person and
I think that's a shame it's a shame for
him and it's a shame for those like me
who see a lot of good in Trump he's been
you know he was very good to me when I
left America left CNN I went back to
Britain I can count on one hand the
number of American people uh in the
business if you like who stayed in touch
with me Trump did he ranged me quite
regularly to check how I was doing could
he help you know he didn't need to do
that so he has got these qualities it's
just I don't see much evidence of it of
him as a political leader he's taken a
different
path well I would say part of that is a
consequence of the fact that the radical
leftists have given it compassion and
empathy a bad name you know and so
because Trump is standing against
especially the
radicals he's being put in a position
where he more oress de facto has to
stand against that kind of smothering
quasi maternal devouring sympathy that's
part and parcel of being allied with the
victims and so part of that's an
ideological problem I would also say
that I believe that there has been no
political figure certainly in my living
memory with the possible exception of
Richard Nixon who's been vilified more
thoroughly and also more falsely than
Trump and I would point to the idiot
conclusion of Russian collusion
especially with regards to the hunter
Biden laptop as evidence in that regard
you know I mean Trump has no shortage of
flaws let's say a statement that can be
said of all of us but apart from vicious
criticism with regard to those faults
there's been an absolute surfite of
devastating criticism and persecution
for faults that are not real and you
know it isn't obvious to me how much a
person can take without starting to feel
continually embattled you know I've
certainly had to fight against the
proclivity to cease turning the other
cheek let's say with regards to those
who regard themselves as my enemies
because if you're gone after enough you
tend to think that the only the best
defense is a good offense let's say and
yeah it's very difficult to plot Your
Way Forward against those kinds of odds
now Trump did go into the White House as
an outsider both on the Republican and
the Democrat front and he has faced no
shortage of impediments and it's a hell
of a lot to ask of someone to take all
that with good graces and he's certainly
done better than he might have in that
regard I mean he's still in the race for
example now you might say well if you
want to be president you better be the
guy that has that kind of largess of
spirit and fair enough
but but you know let him who is without
sin cast the first stone let's say right
um he's an old guy you know and he's
bombastic
and and he's under a lot of pressure and
so and all the lies that have been
generated to Black in his name have made
him a worse
man at least in his public facing image
than he might otherwise have been and I
can't help but see in that also a kind
of Nefarious underhanded plan if you
can't defeat your opponent fair and
square on the field of vision let's say
or compassion then you can do everything
you can to back them into a corner and
provoke them into doing something
reprehensible so that you can blocken
their name and it's certainly the case
that the Democrats have done absolutely
everything they possibly could to do
that say with regard to January 6th
while simultaneously taking no
responsibility whatsoever for the
widespread rioting that accompanied for
example the black lives matter
movement yeah I think it's the double
stand on a lot of this stuff that
enrages a lot of people um if that's
your prediction for the American
election which I think is probably right
now looking quite likely what's your
prediction for the UK election you've
been quite scathing about Sakia stama
but the polls show at the moment
certainly uh if the election happens in
the in the Autumn it seems likely that
he is heading to uh some kind of Victory
what do you think that would mean for
Britain and do the conservatives have
any chance stopping
that I think it'll be
catastrophic I I believe that labor like
the Socialist parties in Canada is
absolutely overwhelmed by the diversity
equity and inclusivity victim victimizer
ative types and that even if starmer
himself has any sense which I doubt the
probability that his minions will lay
waste to the UK is it's certain in my
estimation there's so much behind the
scene tyrannizing going on in the name
of hypothetical utopian progress that
it's almost unimaginable I mean the
cctvs in the ules zones are a great
example of that and everything that's
happened in London under sadik Khan
who's like poster boy for ideologically
addled globalist utopians and if the
labor gets in and I can understand why
the citizens of the UK are hungry for a
change if labor gets in it's like
Venezuela here we come I I think it'll
be I think at minimum the UK will
probably manage to overtake Canada as
worst performing developed country
over the next four decades if they're
foolish enough to elect a labor
government and that's quite AOW that's
quite a what would you say an opponent
to overcome given the state of our
leadership in
Canada yeah it is what are your thoughts
uh Jordan about the two Wars still
raging Ukraine and Russia and of course
Israel and its war in Gaza against
Hamas well I think Ukraine is great news
for the arms manufacturers and the
military industrial complex and that's I
think that's really 90% of the issue
right there I mean it's it's been in
their interest and I say this without
cynicism by the way it's been in their
interest since the demise of the Cold
War to insist upon the positioning of
Russia as the dire enemy of the West I
mean first of all if you're a military
supplier it's your job to be paranoid
and to look for enemies and there's some
utility in that right I mean that's part
of being wise as serpents let's say but
it also means that there's constant
pressure from extremely well-healed
individuals those that run the
military-industrial complex to Dam all
potential Peace Accords with faint
praise and to constantly agitate on the
side of war and preparation thereof
and you the war in Ukraine is a bonanza
for the military-industrial complex and
that's a complete bloody catastrophe we
had a chance especially in the 9s and in
the 2000s for that matter to make a
longstanding peace with Russia not an
easy thing to do especially in the face
of China um and we we burned up that
opportunity like the fools that we are
and here we are with that with regards
to Israel and and Hamas
well a war occurs when people can't
agree and no one we certainly can't
agree on the facts of the matter at hand
with regard to the conflict in Israel my
sense is most fundamentally that it's
been hyper convenient for the radical
islamists especially those in Iran to
have Hamas and the Palestinians suffer
greatly and continually so that they can
be a constant go in the side of Israel
and the US and so we've stepped right
into that that as well um what's the
solution well you know I'd be a fool to
offer one wouldn't I because there's
been a plethora of solutions offered
with regards to Israel and the
Palestinians over the last six decades
and very little progress has been made
on that front and I think the reason for
that is that there are incredibly
entrenched
interests in whose interest it is to
prolong and make as bloody as possible
this conf conflict and so there's no
hope for peace under those circumstances
and for the Islamic fundamentalists
so-called Islamic fundamentalists who
are fostering the conflict what a few
hundred thousand or million Palestinian
lives you know doesn't hurt them if all
those innocent people die so that's a
dreadful
situation
um if I was in is Israel's shoes I
suppose I would likely do much the same
as they are doing with one possible Koda
which is that as Israel becomes more
successful on the military front which
is highly
likely the swing in popular opinion is
likely to
increasingly go against them because
it's a lot easier to trumpet moral
virtue by siding with the hypothetical
victims than it is to celebrate the
accomplishment of the conquerors and so
I'm afraid that one likely outcome for
Israel is that they win militarily but
lose
strategically however we'll see um one
of the things I'm very happy about
however and this is really a miracle and
it's one that we should be very
attentive to is that despite the rising
temperature and costs of this conflict
the Abraham Accords which established a
certain degree of peace between Israel
and a number of states who were
previously in a state of enmity that
Accord has held and that that's the best
news on the geopolitical front that I
can think of in the last 50 years you
know there is some real possibility
still that Israel and its neighbors
could enter into a long-standing and
productive peace and God we could all
pray for that because that would be the
best possible outcome for everyone
involved I'm certain that Iran Iran does
not believe that that
pathway is in their interest and so
they're going to do everything they can
not only to Foster this war which is
what they have been doing but also to
fund and ferment all the protests that
have been racking the Western World in
support hypothetical support of
Hamas let's end on a more positive note
uh Jordan um I could talk to you all day
in fact one day I want to do that it
would be fascinating um you got an
extraordinary mind and you have such an
extraordinary take on all these things
um but let's talk about you and what
your plans are for 2024 I know you got a
a tour you have your Academy and you
have a new
book yes I'm finishing up what I think
will be two books um the first one is
called we who wrestle with God and it's
going to be an analysis of the
fundamental stories of the western world
and so that really means a Biblical
analysis I did a series of lectures in
2017 on Genesis which were very well
received including by atheists and then
also a seminar last year on Exodus and
in this book I've walked through uh a
good sampling of the major biblical
stories attempting to explain in so far
as I am capable what they mean one book
is going to focus on the Old Testament
and another the other on the New
Testament and I'm finishing those up now
that'll constitute the content for the
tour that my wife and I are going on
with some special guests including
Jonathan pasio that will run from
February through May um 51 cities across
the United States and then off to
Central and South America and I'm very
much excited about doing that and
recording it and releasing those
recordings live the reason this is so
important Pierce is
because our world depends on Stories
the the Integrity of our psyches is
predicated on the unity and
functionality of the stories that guide
our perceptions and our emotions and our
social stability is predicated on the
sharing of a universal narrative that's
what it means for a culture to be United
in belief and commitment and conviction
and For Better or Worse the uniting
stories of the West are those derived
from the judeo-christian tradition and
we've
lost contact with them we've we've
sought off the branch that we sit on and
part of the reason for that is that in
some way we never really understood the
stories but we willing to act as if or
believe that they were true but we're
now at a point where
partly because of the conflict between
the scientific mind and the religious
mind we not only have to believe we have
to understand and what I'm trying to do
is to make that understanding possible
you can see the consequences of this
beginning to unfold by the way um more
publicly major figures who were what
would you say spokespeople for the new
atheist Community Douglas Murray Ayan
hery Ali Neil Ferguson among them Brett
Weinstein for that matter have begun to
realize that our conceptions are
embedded in a narrative substrate
they're embedded in a religious story
and that story in some ways can't be
replaced substitutes can be slaughtered
in but they tend to be devastating
ideologies of the sort that
characterized let's say the Soviet Union
or a soul devouring nihilism
and so I'm writing as deeply as I can
about the stories that guide us and I
hope to bring what I've being privileged
to investigate to as wide an audience as
possible I'm also going to do a gospel
seminar with many of the same thinkers
that I conducted The Exodus seminar with
in April for the same reason and so I'm
extremely excited about that I I can't
really imagine doing anything more
interesting or having a privilege that's
greater than having the opportunity to
make what I know public during this tour
as I said a tour of 50 cities very
extensive so and then in
February I'm doing a soft launch with my
daughter of Peterson Academy which is
our attempt to rectify the abysmal
situation that modern institutions of
higher education have landed themselves
in and to provide the opportunity for
people all over the world to obtain a
highquality general University level
education very efficiently hopefully
enjoyably and at a low cost I would say
we're going to drop the price of a
bachelor's degree by
95% and I can't imagine anything being
timed better than that especially in the
aftermath of the absolute catastrophe
that the presidents of upan MIT and
Harvard have made of their uh Associated
institutions yeah I mean we haven't
touched on that but just quickly what
what was your view of that it looked to
me like finally the chickens came home
to roost with the people that led those
colleges who've been basically attacking
Free Speech now for a number of
years
well I when I watched it I watched it in
jaw dropped amazement I felt well what
this is the testimony in DC of the three
University presidents I thought two
things I thought it's a complete bloody
miracle that these people who've been
clamoring for the Restriction of free
speech on the basis of Oppression and
harm can't admit
that c calls for the genocide of Jews no
matter how arguably tangential don't
violate these incredibly restrictive
Free Speech codes which they themselves
have been screeching about like mad
harpies for decades so that was just a
bloody Miracle of blind stupidity and it
was a catastrophe as far as I was
concerned that it characterized
particularly MIT and Harvard because
those were great places and then to Ally
that with the implicit presumption as
they did that it was self-evident that
the moral stance that those same
presidents took would be met with by the
general public with nothing but open
armed appreciation was also an
indication of absolutely how absolutely
demented and and self- deluding the
universities have become and I say that
apart from my financial interest in
making Peterson Academy work let's say
and my moral interest as well I say that
with no satisfaction whatsoever I worked
at Harvard for six years and I loved it
it was a great place and the halfwit
Pharisees scribes and lawyers have you
know wormed their way in with their
idiot ideological moralizing and
devastated those institutions you know
and people like Bill Amman who sort of
led the charge along with Christ for
rufo with regard to Claudine gay the
president of Harvard they've started to
wake up to How Deep The Rot goes but you
know they've just barely scraped the
surface so many of our institutions of
higher learning including those devoted
to the hypothetically scientific
Endeavor have become corrupted to the
point where replacement is likely the
only possible way forward you know like
could Harvard find its way once again
well maybe if you did what Elon Musk did
when he took over Twitter and fired
95% of the administrators and a fair
number of the faculty but who are you
going to get to replace them
and who's going to do that no parallel
institutions are the name of the game
now and you see that with the University
of Austin you see it with Ralston
College in Savannah and that's what
we're going to try to do with Peterson
Academy all the quality at 12th the
price and hopefully a limited amount of
ideological
moralizing we have great professors man
we've got 30 professors who've already
taped courses so I love the uh I love
the ambition for this uh Jordan I've got
to leave it there I don't want to but
we've run out of time thank you so much
for joining me a perfect way to start Pi
Morgan uncensored for 2024 I wish you as
I said a very happy New Year all the
best with your your expanding family and
I hope to catch up with you again
soon thanks Pierce it's always a
pleasure to talk to
you